why haven't you sacked those shadow
ministers who disobeyed your direct
orders well i was very clear that a
responsible government gets the
negotiating parties around
the table
and that's why i took the approach that
i did the chief whip has now dealt with
those that didn't follow the advice and
that's a perfectly satisfactory outcome
now the treasury fears that there might
be a wider wage price spiral as a result
of uh demands for ever increasing wages
against this backdrop of high inflation
your spokesman uh earlier this week
suggested that you don't fear a wage
price spiral why is that well the first
thing to do is put responsibility where
it lies and i know the government says
sort of master class in blaming
everybody else we've had an economy that
hasn't grown for 10 years that's the
cause of the situation that we're in at
the moment low wages for 10 years low
growth for 10 years and now we've got
high inflation and high taxation the
government's decided to impose higher
taxation on people highest taxation for
decades in the middle of a cost of
living crisis so the responsibility for
the situation we find ourselves in is
with the government what i want to do
is to have an emergency budget so we can
actually tackle the cost of living
crisis reduce those tax increases deal
with and help businesses that are really
really struggling to bring down the risk
of inflation so i say again to the
government if you're really serious
about dealing with the cost of living
crisis let's have an emergency budget
there's still time in this parliamentary
term and we want to see that budget
brought forward so to be clear on that
issue of a wage spice a wage price
spiral
do you see evidence for a potentially
for that to come about or or not well
look i think the uh situation that we
find ourselves in is the cause of the
government in the autumn
the prime minister was saying we're
going to have a high-wage economy
encouraging people down this route now
he's created the conditions by
putting up taxes in the middle of a cost
of living crisis where people are really
struggling talk to the residents here in
crawley i spoke to one woman this
morning she's doing three jobs because
she can't make ends meet she and i are
calling on the government an emergency
budget to sort this out including
reversing these tax
increases which are really really
hurting people